any woman can get breast cancer men too
in fact so that's why it's important to
check your breasts regularly a new
campaign has been launched using a poem
and illustrations to help promote
regular checks and ensure people
understand the signs and symptoms of
breast cancer let's take a look
this is the way to examine your chest
topless in front of a mirror is best if
your breasts are fairly Hefty lift them
up righty Lefty have a snoop beneath
each one then turn to the side for a
look once that's done
you're looking for lumps on the surface
of the skin you're checking to see if
the nipples pulled in look out for a
puckering dimple or tether
now raise your arms up high together
this position may help reveal a bump or
lump your breasts conceal
well joining us now is the consultant
breast surgeon and two-time breast
cancer survivor uh Dr Liz o'riordan
hello to you Doctor thank you for
joining us so tell me how all of this
came about it was some of the
illustrations around us we're chatting
so I'm a breast surgeon who's had breast
cancer and hands up I never check my
breasts and I realized so many of my
patients didn't know how to do so in
lockdown I just put a video online
showing people and Laura Bradford the
poet behind this contacted me and said
I'm 37 and I didn't know this I want to
make a poem that's catchy that's not
scary and she reached out to the
incredible artist LMA Statham who got
women of all shapes and sizes to come
and act as models just to create
something that we can help Every Woman
check their breasts and I've been blown
away by the response why do you think it
is first of all that women don't know
how to do it and then
even if they did have an idea that a lot
of women just don't check their breasts
I mean I never did I was a breast
surgeon I thought it wouldn't happen to
me I don't think we're taught at schools
you may see little videos online but
that's not how a breast surgeon does it
my mum didn't tell me how to do it and I
just think especially when you're young
and you mammograms don't work it's the
one thing you have to pick up breast
cancer early and that's why we've
created this free resource to try and
help Every Woman learn what to do
although ultrasounds help a little bit
ultrasounds are great for lumps but
they're not great for screening the
whole breast and we don't that's why
young women don't get mammograms because
their breasts are too dense to see a
cancer okay so
um tell us what women should do
obviously we've got the illustrations
behind and where can we find this so at
the moment it's just on our Instagram
account
um and we're hoping that we can create a
website to share this all over the world
get it translated just for free you need
to look at your breasts you need to feel
them you need to check your armpits it's
all in the poem and if there's anything
you're worried about let your GP know
when do you need to do it if you have
periods then you should do it in the
middle of your cycle when your breasts
are less lumpy if you stopped having
periods then pick a date and a lot of
people go for the first of the month and
is it once a month every month I do when
you're in the shower in ideally when
you're lying flat in bed rest up in a
couple of pillows especially if you have
large breasts otherwise you're not
feeling the breast tissue and we talk
about that in the poem tell me what
happened to you so I was 40 I was a
consultant breast surgeon and I had a
lump I ignored it my mum said get it
checked out and it was a stage three
breast cancer wow yeah stage three stage
three goodness and it came back on my
chest wall a couple of years later which
meant I had to retire so I now spend my
time doing this just to help educate
women when you say on your chest well
difficult to feel it there I thought it
was a nodular scar tissue and I'm a
consultant breast surgeon and I didn't
know if you are if you find a lump yeah
what do you do it's really scary and
most women with lumps aren't cancer but
what I tell anyone to do is go and see
their GP they will refer you into a
breast clinic and they can do the scans
and hopefully put your mind at ease yeah
as you say most lumps are not I mean I
have had several lumps removed
thankfully none of them touch would have
been cancer but it it is scary it's very
sad and you didn't go even though you
found a lump why did you not go I just
thought it's not so I've had to test it
before I'm not worried about this when I
look the same and it was my mum who said
look I'm worried and she was right and
that fear of what if can be paralyzing
how did you get together with the lady
that wrote the poem and also how did you
then decide how to illustrate it so
Laura Bradford who wrote it who lives in
France contacted me and said I've seen
your video I'm inspired I want to make
something that's not scary that's
accessible and her aunt to a secondary
breast cancer
um said there's potential in this I'm
going to pay for you to have it
Illustrated and Laura reached out to LMA
Statham who got women to send in
photographs of themselves of all shapes
and sizes so we can make it real and you
can find yourself in this poem and think
I can do this am I right in saying that
men can contract yes men do you get
breast cancer it's rare but it does
happen they also get mammograms and
we've had incredible men sharing it
yesterday even though it was
International women's day okay and as
far as men are concerned same things
apply but even more difficult to get
them to go to the doctor it's scary and
again being in a clinic full of women
it's not something that men normally
feel comfortable with especially when
breast cancer is mainly pink media but
if you notice bleeding on your nipple
you have a lump you should also get it
checked out and okay
um and how's your health now all clear
touchwood fantastic it's great to hear
thank you very much explaining that to
us and we can find it on your Instagram
at the moment Instagram at the moment
and we're hoping someone will help us
get a resource so we can share it well
let's see what we can do about that
what's the Instagram
um I'm erid and Liz yeah and the author
is totally telling Tales that's Laura
Bradford's account so you can find it
when we clip this up for our Twitter
feed we'll make sure we say that as well
thank you very much thank you great to
see you thank you